Hello, everybody. Welcome to another read your team's podcast.
So let's jump right in with a few questions that we have.
How to read the full genetic report one versus two. So I think this person is asking,
what is the best way to read?
So when you get a genetic review from us, you get the full genetic report,
which is well over a couple hundred pages.
And then you get the genetic summary report, which is around 20 pages.
And then you get the genetic action step report, which is just a few pages.
So if you want to dig into the full report to see different things, you certainly can.
When it shows a one or a two, that means you either have a single allele defect,
a one or a double allele defect, a two.
So again, remember, just because you have a two on a gene doesn't mean the gene doesn't work.
It just means that there's a good chance that that gene could be hindered in its function.
Now there are a few defects or allele, you know, ones or twos that actually can benefit us as far as health goes.
For instance, the dairy gene in the in the genetic profile.
If you have defects, you actually retain the ability to break down lactose.
So remember the dairy genes are not looking at your ability to break down the dairy protein casing.
Nor are the HLA genes in with gluten in indication that you for sure have a gluten sensitivity.
Even if you have twos on there and on the genes for more serious gluten issues, even if you have twos on there doesn't mean you definitely are going to have gluten issues.
This means it increases that risk. Now, if you have twos on the dairy genes, it actually means that you retain the ability to break down lactose.
And you will probably be able to consume dairy better than if somebody did not have any defects.
There was no, there was just blank, so it doesn't show a zero if there's no defects if it's that's called so called the wild for the gene, meaning there's no defects on the gene.
So there's some defects that actually would give us better lifestyle changes meaning that now you could maybe eat dairy, at least you would have the ability to break down the lactose so you might not be lactose intolerant.
That being said, with something like dairy 90% of the people that have issues with dairy. It's not the lactose. It's the case scene.
They have develops antibodies to the case scene. So they have a dairy allergy. There's difference between a dairy allergy, quote unquote sensitivity because you have antibodies to casing the protein and dairy versus a lactose inability to break down lactose.
Meaning you don't make lactase the enzyme very well.
So totally different things, but when you read the full report and you're looking at that, some people also get very concerned because a gene family, let's use the, let's use the pun one gene family, for instance, those are, that's the pun one pathway of detoxification part of your phase to detoxification pathway in your liver.
Let's say you have, you know, out of that family that is shown on your report, I don't know how many genes are shown, maybe five or 10 genes in the pun one pathway family, let's say you have two zone three of those genes.
Well, does it mean that you're, you know, your detox pathways in your liver are completely shot or anything. It just means that you may have more issues with phase two pathway and you might be a slower detoxer.
As far as your liver detox pathways go, that's what that means. That's why I try to summarize it in the summary report. I know I think it's very confusing.
People get very concerned when they look at their genes and they think, oh my gosh, I have a defect out of this pathway, that means, you know, my body is, you know, not going to work correctly.
It's so much of your genetics as you'll see throughout if you spend some time in the course and look at this.
Yes, these genes can be important and can affect our life and you can make some epigenetic changes based upon knowledge of these genes, but don't think that you're doomed because you have genetic defects.
So, but that's what it one in the two means it does get confusing and you do need to study a lot to really kind of figure out what these different pathways are.
Next question, could you briefly give an overview of the different pathways covered and briefly what they do.
Are they all portions from that big chart we see in the videos, I am trying to grasp the big idea.
Yes and no, so the big chart that you see in the videos is really only a piece of it.
So the big chart that you see in the video does not include all the genes.
But it includes the major ones, so there's more genes than just than what are shown in that big chart, but that big chart gives you a good kind of overview of some of the major pathways.
It'd be really hard to give a brief overview of the different pathways because you're looking at a lot of different pathways, your genetic report covers hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of genes.
So that's why we created the course and that's why we created all the videos that go along with the course.
But the big idea to grasp that big idea would be to that we're looking at the major metabolic pathways, how your body processes nutrients, how your body gets rid of chemicals, how your body makes enzymes, how your body, you know functions to make energy to get rid of poisons.
That's what the full genetic report is looking at those genes now understand there's other genes that just haven't been well researched that are actually included in what is tested for, but there's just not enough knowledge.
So it's not even included in that full report is not enough knowledge to give you any data on it because there's just so much research that has to go on yet as far as genetics.
That's why when we first started to read these genetic reviews that the full genetic report was like 50 pages long now it's what is it 200 and some pages long it just keeps getting longer so as new research comes out.
It is it gives us more data so so then we then that report is expanded on so some people have contacted us that have done a genetic review with us like 678 years ago and they say should I run my genetics again well the answer is no.
But there's a caveat to that so if what we when we first used to run genetics we didn't have our own genetic test kit and we ran 23 and me and we use that data from 23 and me to put into the report and that gave us about a 40 30 to 50 page report I think when I first started was like 28 pages.
And and then 23 and me actually started truncating their data meaning that they didn't test for as many genes because they were trying to compete price wise with ancestor.com and they started testing less metabolic genes so they were testing more ancestral type genes so we dropped 23 and me plus I didn't trust 23 and these ability to keep people's data safe.
So that was that was a gosh that was a long time ago and then we started up with the supplementation testing about four or five years ago and the we're testing many more gene some sets of gene families so it gave us a bigger picture of a person's health picture so the report was well over 100 pages.
Well as new data comes in on some of the genes that are tested but yet don't appear in your full report the full report gets bigger and bigger and bigger so if a person did a genetic work up with us.
Back when we were doing 23 and me then yes we should run a new fully new kit get your saliva sample again and do a fully new kit because we're testing for you know thousands and thousands of thousands of more genes than 23 me ever tested for so you're going to get a much more.
For a health full you know picture of what your overall health is as far as genetics goes if you did a test with us under the DNA supplementation saliva kit so maybe you did it four years ago but your report that was only 120 pages you could ask for a new report because the the genes were tested but the data wasn't there yet.
So as data comes in as you know we're constantly adding to that report.
It doesn't completely answer this question could you give me a big picture of what's going on or what's being tested.
We try to separate it out into the most logically understandable way to separate out the genes.
There's some genes that that the known function kind of crosses a couple different metabolic systems meaning it's not necessarily digested but it might be detoxification or one gene might affect detox and might affect the digestion so you'll see actually in the full report.
The gene like the CTH gene is in a couple different categories the glutathione gene is in some of the glutathione genes are in a couple different categories.
The glutathione has to do with detoxification mainly cellular detoxification but it also affects is functioning in the liver with detoxification so it's in with the liver detox genes but it's in with its own category.
It does get complicated because your body's complicated so it's hard to give really you know a brief summary of that that's probably the briefest summary that I could give hopefully that helped answer the question.
But it does you know a lot of people get frustrated because they're like oh my gosh I don't want to listen to all these videos on these different genes.
But there's just no other way to do it because there's just so much education that needs to say place and there's more new information coming out you know what a regular basis that's why I'm trying to add videos on a fairly regular basis as well.
Can I get genetic testing for my family members what is a good time to consider this did we answer this question a few weeks ago.
But yes you can do it on your family members you really have to wait until a person can spit into a tube we used to have a cheek swab kit but they pulled that for a while they're having some troubles with it.
But I don't know if that is back up again if we could do the cheek swabs you know that would be for people who can't spit into a tube so it would be for younger children.
Now again like I said last week when I answered this you know if you had the genetics of the father and the mother you could kind of extrapolate a little bit what troubles the child is possibly going to have.
Because if the mom has a single allele defect and the father has a single allele defect the child's going to have definitely have a defect to both the mother and the father have double allele defects the child's going to have a double allele defect in that gene.
So if you had genetics of the father and mother you would necessarily have to look at each child certainly if a child one of your children is having issues you could look at it kid a child have defects that the parents don't have the answers yes because the child could have acquired defects not inherited defects.
So an acquired defect has to do with something they were exposed to the damage to gene so could a vaccine damage cause an acquired defect well possibly.
You know there's just they just won't allow studies on the stuff the you know what order to do a study you have to you know to have a published study you have to get approval through the FDA they will never approve some sort of study like that that would show.
The lyrics effects of vaccines or medications but that simply is true that those can cause defects when you think we got all these defects in the first place you know are you know I it's really interesting because I've seen people's genetics you know I've looked at thousands of people's genetics now and the older the person is the cleaner their genes are.
It's just you know I just looked at a person's genes this is a couple weeks ago we got some sets in and the person was in their 80s and I thought oh my goodness actually told what am I stamping them this person's genes are the clearest I've ever seen without that you their name but they're but then you see people in their 20s
with just a lot of defects so I do believe that it's because of the chemicals in our environment that are affecting us and damaging our our genetics and you know they're not something that goes away that's not something that gets corrected it you'll pass it down to your children it's just kind of sad what's happening to our environment.
But remember again even if you have a lot of defects even if you have you know on your pond one genes use that as an example again your major detoxification pathway if you had tools on all the genes and that family it still doesn't mean that they're not going to work completely it just means that you're really probably going to be a slow detoxer and you should make epigenetic changes make sure you're not exposed to glyphosate make sure you're not exposed to chemical.
Toxins is best as you can all these things that you do knowing your genetics are things that we should do anyhow you know so but when you look at your genetics it gives us a sense of motivation I think at least to go holy cow by glutathione pathway is you know it's just horrible I need to keep taking glutathione or to keep taking you know precursors to glutathione.
To help support that or by you know pod pathways are horrible I'm going to keep taking support for that and make sure about you know eating out very much because I'm not going to probably get organic and I'm going to be exposed to a lot of chemicals that I don't want to be exposed to I'm not going to be eating you know candy with dyes in it I'm not going to be eating you know it gives you some motivation to stay in a track when we have so much pressure to be to go off of our diet to go awful.
You know what we know is better for us.
Okay thanks for being on today keep your questions coming in and we'll see you in two weeks.